c
on
bonsoir le 19/20 ne faillira pas à la
tradition en ce lundi de pentecôte il
sera riche en manifestations et
cérémonies rituelles l'aï pour
religieuses culturelles et politiques
avec notamment le pèlerinage des
catholiques traditionalistes de paris à
chartres et des intégristes de chartres
à paris avec également le palmarès du
44e festival de cannes la liturgie a
commencé avec enfin l'ascension de la
roche de solutré par françois mitterrand
et les siens cette image là nous
n'aurions pas dû la voir
françois mitterrand avait fait savoir
qu'il ne gravirait pas la roche cette
fois mais les journalistes les plus
consciencieux et le plus tenace ont tout
de même
rodez dans le coin et ils ont bien fait
parmi eux michel le maire et christophe
carnez l'ascension de la roche de
solutré se résume désormais pour le
président en une difficile équation
comment respecter une tradition à
laquelle il est fortement attaché tout
en évitant ceux qui sont tentés de
profiter de l'occasion pour satisfaire
de manière trop pressante curiosité ou
revendication recettes brouiller les
pistes être bien renseigné sur les
déplacements les horaires des
indésirables et s'est lancé dès l'aube
au moment où l'on s'y attend le moins
résultat une ascension sereine le
sourire aux lèvres et la canne à la main
en devisant tranquillement avec jack
lang roger hanin ou georges kiejman avec
juste ce qu'il faut de objectif au
sommet pour immortaliser la scène
de ce point de vue mission 91 réussi
mais pour les confidences politiques ce
n'était pas un grand cru
les proches du président hutu juste
confié qu'il avait trouvé excellente
hier soir la prestation d'edith cresson
à la télévision mais manifestement le
président n'avait pas envie de répondre
à des questions trop précises c'est vrai
que c'est ici l'an passé qu'il avait
vanté les mérites de michel rocard
françois mitterrand était venu avant
tout pour respecter la tradition
il n'est surtout pas question de
l'interrompre il nous a d'ailleurs
quitté sur un malicieux à l'année
prochaine
vous avez eu l'image mais pas le son
françois mitterrand a tenu à respecter
la trêve de pentecôte
après la semaine politique très dense
qui nous a fait vivre
mais cette trêve sera de courte durée
dès mercredi edith cresson présentera
son programme à l'assemblée nationale un
programme dont on connaît la couleur
grâce à ses multiples interventions
notamment à tf1 hier soir
le premier ministre tient à faire de la
lutte contre le chômage une l'une de ses
priorités
le super ministère dirigé par pierre
bérégovoy doit être at-elle dit une
usine à emploi et bien il y a un secteur
est une région qui attendent beaucoup de
cette usine
le textile dans le nord dans la seule
région nord-pas-de-calais cent mille
emplois ont en effet été supprimée en
dix ans dans le textile et la crise
n'est pas finie la lainière de roubaix
serait en effet en faillite sans
intervention du gouvernement
l'entreprise et les 4000 salariés du
groupe sont en sursis
reportage sur place de claude rey coup
claude guaino et raymond sarde a mis au
coeur de roubaix véritable château fort
usine la filature motte-bossut en pleine
rénovation et a échappé de justesse aux
démolisseurs c'était une filature très
importante à roubaix et ce bâtiment va
devenir un musée il va avoir en son sein
des archives du monde du travail
parce que maintenant les filatures c'est
l'histoire voilà tout à fait signature
c'est l'histoire quand même profonde de
roubaix le passé c'est aussi cet autre
filature devenu terrain vague
on a prévu d'y construire des bureaux le
chantier est en panne faute d'activité
suffisante
ancienne capitale de la laine roubaix
est rongé par la crise du textile
ces usines ont fermé ou licencier à tour
de bras je tends la rue 30000 personnes
depuis dix ans
les entreprises qui ont connu des
problèmes ont connu des problèmes déjà
depuis la des années 70 75 écran
licenciement de tous ils ont commencé à
cette époque si la lp eux était une
usine avec plus de 6000 inscrits celle
de wattrelos ville soeur de roubaix
serait le plus gros employeur avant même
la redoute
ici le chômage touche 12 % de la
population 3 points de plus que le reste
de la france
malgré tout la situation a tendance à
s'améliorer
ce n'est pas que l'on crée beaucoup
d'emplois mais les habitants fuient la
région le nombre de petites maisons de
brique à vendre atteint des records
depuis dix ans et a tout retardé les
sentiments
ce n'est rien la survie de la lainière
de roubaix c'est la grande préoccupation
ses effectifs de 8000 sont tombés à 12
cents la maison-mère bâti sur les restes
des empires robots et boussac affiche
800 millions de pertes et des dettes de
près de 3 milliards au bord de la
faillite le gouvernement a lancé un plan
de sauvetage de la lainière
on est dans un fief du parti socialiste
et puis on est à la veille
enfin la veille ou l'avant-veille
d'élections donc le gouvernement
intervient c'est une bonne chose pour
nous mais c'est cher ça va coûter cher
nous rappelons aussi aux différents
patrons il s'agit pas d'être capitaliste
pour empocher les bénéfices et d'être
socialiste pour partager les pertes
dressé par le gouvernement est accusé
d'avoir fêté les yeux fermés les banques
tiennent à bout de bras la lainière et
le groupe à coups de millions mais pour
les députés socialistes c'est un plan de
sauvetage du textile qui est nécessaire
un millier de salariés ont été licenciés
depuis janvier sur roubaix tourcoing du
goulag à la vraie liberté l'union
soviétique pour a franchi aujourd'hui un
grand pas vers la démocratie
les soviétiques pourront désormais
voyager sans crainte et sans entraves
selon les premières estimations d'éclat
loi entrera en vigueur cinq à sept
millions de soviétiques se rendront
immédiatement à l'étranger mais pour le
moment aucun calendrier n'a été précisé
et la loi ne devrait être effectif qu'en
1993 morad aït habbouche devant
l'ambassade des états unis à moscou des
centaines de candidats à l'exil se
pressent la loi vient pourtant à peine
d'être voté par le soviet suprême comme
ces soviétique
ils sont des millions dans le pays a
rêvé de l'occident la levée du dernier
rideau de fer transforme le rêve en
réalité
mais la prudence reste de mise nous
pouvons espérer mais vraiment je n'y
crois pas peut-être un peu enfin
sûrement pas de grand changement si les
soviétiques peuvent désormais quitter
leur pays librement
ils vont devoir patienter avant de le
faire pas avant janvier 93
mais pour eux ce ne sera de toute façon
plus un casse-tête les visas de sortie
ne sont plus obligatoires
seul à visa du pays d'accueil sera exigé
reste que les aéroports déjà surchargés
vont devoir être agrandi les lignes
aériennes multiplier un investissement
con
d'érable rarement en tout cas un projet
de loi n'aura été disputé autant au
soviet suprême
il est vrai qu'un exode massif inquiète
les autorités il y a un an une porte
avait été ouverte avec israël et déjà
plus de deux cent mille juifs
soviétiques sont partis s'installer dans
l'état hébreu
plus alarmant les chercheurs les
intellectuels les artistes risquent
d'être les plus tenté par l'eldorado
occidental une fuite des cerveaux
d'autant plus dramatique que l'urss a
besoin de toutes ses énergies pour
éviter le désastre économique
le grand pardon en israël celui de lech
walesa qui au nom des polonais a demandé
aux israéliens de pardonner les fautes
et les persécutions commises contre les
juifs dans son pays l'esbva l'état est
arrivé en fin de matinée en israël où il
restera quatre jours voyage qui se veut
décisif dans le processus de
normalisation entre les deux pays
le président polonais l'a affirmé avant
de partir ces donations éprouvée par
l'histoire doivent se parler clair
sébastien il y a eu parmi les polonais
des gens qui ont fait le mal ici un
israël berceau de votre renaissance je
vous demande officiellement pardon un
pardon qui rachèterait tous les crimes
des polonais à la knesset en ce jour de
pentecôte walesa est passé d'un extrême
à l'autre soupçonné d'antisémitisme
il vient d'offrir le visage d'un
rédempteur le chef de l'état polonais
qui effectue pour la première fois une
visite de quatre jours en israël a
déposé une gerbe au mémorial élevé en
souvenir des six millions de juifs
exterminés par les nazis
trois millions d'entre eux résident et
en pologne ils ne sont plus aujourd'hui
que 10000 par son mea culpa
le président valaisanne a voulu effacer
les fautes des polonais mais aussi les
maladresses de l'électricien de danse en
campagne électorale
je suis 100% polonais avait-il déclaré
en novembre dernier des propos de
campagne que beaucoup avaient jugé
emprunt antisémitisme depuis lech walesa
avait tout fait pour gommer cette image
lors de son voyage à paris en avril
dernier il avait tenu à rassurer les
représentants de la communauté juive de
france
aujourd'hui le pardon de jérusalem
la pologne de ces crimes eva l'égard de
tout ce grand dégel à l'est ne va pas
sans secousses c'est le cas de la
yougoslavie qui tente de préserver son
unité
mais difficilement les croates ont voté
hier à une écrasante majorité pour la
création d'un état souverain et
indépendant libre de s'associer ou non
aux autres républiques de la fédération
yougoslave
nouvelle preuve de cette volonté
d'indépendance la naissance ce matin un
journal croate zapad est un nouveau
quotidien imprimé à zagreb
mais son équipe ne veut pas exacerber
les problèmes entre serbes et croates
pour ne pas provoquer de nouveaux
incidents reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux
jean-paul girouard et philippe guinet
zapad en crois tu l'ouest la position
géographique de la croatie au sein de la
yougoslavie mais aussi l'endroit vers
lequel se tourne ses regards l'ouest
l'europe
la pad c'est aussi le titre est la
référence de ce journal nouveau né qui
s'inspire du journal espagnol el país et
qui se revendique premier quotidien
indépendant de croatie dans l'ensemble
du pays
la presse a quitté c'est tutelle
communiste pour se jeter dans le sillage
des nationalistes de tous bords
résultat les journalistes du ghost avons
largement participé à la montée de la
tension entre serbes et croates
notamment une logique de guerre que
zapad entend bien éviter cela fait deux
ou trois ans et c'est la première fois
depuis la guerre
une telle haine entre les peuples et
provoqué par les journalistes c'est pour
ça qu'on veut faire quelque chose de
différent un journal européen
complètement indépendant et objectif et
surtout sans haine
le résultat du référendum d'hier n'a
surpris personne comme 94 % de leurs
concitoyens les journalistes de zapata
veulent que leur république prenne ses
distances avec la fédération yougoslave
asa pad comme partout la seule
divergence entre froide c'est le degré
d'indépendance qu'ils veulent takeri
ici plus personne ne croit à la
fédération actuelle
en fait il y à une moitié de gens qui
sont favorables à une confédération de
républiques souveraines et une autre
moitié pour une indépendance
une séparation totale de la yougoslavie
le premier numéro deux à pattes devait
sortir lundi dernier mais des pressions
venues de proches du nouveau pouvoir
droite ont empêché sa parution de
nombreux croates pense qu'une fois leurs
problèmes d'indépendance réglé il faudra
travailler à une meilleure démocratie
pourra pad ça commencé ce matin retour
en france avec un geste de solidarité
spectaculaire de la part de l'abbé
pierre qui a décidé de soutenir des
immigrés en faisant avec que la grève de
la faim écoutons son témoignage
recueilli par laurence bobillier madame
messieurs vous savez comment en
plusieurs villes de france des hommes
depuis des semaines pour certains c'est
près de deux mois c'est à dire près de
la main ont séché de membres et ce n'est
pas possible pour la france pour tout
humain de supporter je dois considérer
un petit bout une réponse à leur appel
un chauffeur de taxi de 62 ans abattu
froidement parce qu'il résistait à deux
voleurs cela s'est passé voire arrêté
dans la matinée les deux hommes les deux
meurtriers présumés ont reconnu les
faits ils sauront ils seront présentés
demain au parquet du havre
reportage sur place de marc saikali
22h15 hier soir à la gare sncf du havre
claude dupuis charge de jeunes hommes
l'un d'eux cache dans son imperméable un
fusil à pompe
le taxi une mercedes noire des mares de
kilomètres plus loin dans le tunnel
génèrent les deux malfaiteurs tentent de
voler la voiture afin de commettre un
hold up
le chauffeur qui se sentait menacé
résiste réussi en klaxonnant a alerté
ses collègues et s'arrête sur la place
jean françois un ebroïcien de 25 ans
descend alors de la voiture et tire à
travers la vitre claude dupuis est tué
sur le coup une balle en pleine tête
le meurtrier présumé sort le corps de la
voiture étant en compagnie de son
complice williams 23 ans de prendre la
fuite mais prise en chasse par les
chauffeurs de taxi arrivé quelques
minutes plus tard sur les lieux
il abandonne le véhicule et se réfugie
dans la forêt de montgeon toute la nuit
police et des chauffeurs de taxi
patrouille sans résultat à 6h ce matin
c'est au domicile de l'un d'entre eux
que les deux individus sont arrêtés aux
arbres en quinze ans c'est le deuxième
assassinat du genre et ce matin les
chauffeurs de taxis étaient consternés
les deux agresseurs qui ont reconnu les
faits sont actuellement entendus dans
les locaux de l'hôtel de police du havre
ils seront vraisemblablement présenté
demain au parquet les taxis eux sont en
deuil et la nouvelle de cannes nous
arrive à l'instant la palme d'or du 44e
festival de cannes a été décernée à
barton fink des américains john et ethan
coen nous reviendrons sur tout le
palmarès dans quelques instants avec
thierry stampfler polémique sur les
chiens dressés pour être méchant en
grande bretagne samedi soir une fillette
de 10 ans a été grièvement blessé au
visage et sur le corps défigurés par les
morsures d'un pitbull il faut
malheureusement ce genre de drames pour
que la polémique sur ses chiens souvent
dangereux soient lancées reportage
bertrand edel lorsqu'il est en colère
cet animal est capable de tuer son
adversaire
ce jour là cet employé de la fourrière
américaine a eu de la chance elle s'en
est tirée
malgré de profondes morsures à une main
et à la poitrine
la puissance de la mâchoire d'un pitbull
développe une pression redoutable dès le
19ème siècle on le dressay pour l'attack
et le combat aujourd'hui il est l' arme
préférée des revendeurs de drogue aux
états unis
régulièrement la presse américaine
relate les méfaits de ces monstres
assoiffés de sang qui s'entraînent
généralement au visage et à la poitrine
de leurs victimes
pourtant aux dires de certains
spécialistes du comportement animal
le pitbull n'est pas un chien plus
féroce qu'un autre son agressivité
serait due essentiellement au milieu
dans lequel il vit
sur le plan psychique il a pas plus
l'attention de mordre aucun autre chien
le seul problème du pitbull c'est que
s'ils vous mort il vous fait beaucoup
plus mal qu'un autre alors bien sûr il a
été tellement médiatisé que les gens qui
souhaitent avoir un chien dangereux sur
le plan de sa capacité physique vont
saisir le pitbull et vont l'orienter
dans ce sens là le dresser à mordre et
c'est là aujourd'hui la phobie du pit
bull n'a pas encore gagné la france
l'élevage y est pratiquement inexistant
pourtant chez nous le problème existe
chaque année 500 mille plaintes sont
déposées à la suite de morsures de
chiens dans ce domaine la législation
reste souple on ne peut pas obliger un
propriétaire à faire abattre un animal
dangereux sauf si celui ci est atteint
de la rage
didier aurillac résume les autres
événements couverts en france par nos
rédactions régionales
quatre personnes deux enfants et deux
militaires ont été grièvement brûlés au
cours d'un feu d'artifice amateurs tiré
dans le jardin d'une maison à thierville
près de verdun
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
l'adjudant du régiment d'artillerie de
marine chez qui l'accident est survenu
aurait répandu de la poudre par terre
avant d'y mettre le feu provoquant ainsi
un un sens
nouvelle reconstitution aujourd'hui dans
la sphère luc tangorre cet homme inculpé
en 88 pour le viol de deux américaines
près de nîmes
six mois après avoir été gracié pour une
série de viols qu'il avait toujours nié
et de jeune femme l'avait formellement
reconnu
et pourtant selon luc tangorre onze
personnes peuvent témoigner de sa
présence à marseille au moment du crime
incendie la nuit dernière dans une usine
textile de colmar 3000 mètres carrés ont
été détruits il aura fallu plus de trois
heures à une centaine de pompiers pour
venir à bout des flammes
le sinistre ne devrait pas avoir de
conséquence sociale lançant des ateliers
de production puis en effet être sauvé
on ignore pour l'instant l'origine de
l'incendié
un centre de recherche sur le sida au
centre d'une polémique lancée par la
ligue des droits de l'homme
ce centre l'institut godinot installé à
reims est accusé de ne pas appliquer les
règles de sécurité pendant le transport
du sang en raison de ces négligences
plusieurs personnes auraient pu être
contaminées l'accusation est basé sur un
dossier constitué par des techniciens
travaillant au sein même de l'institut
l'enquêté a été confiée à la direction
régionale des affaires sanitaires et
sociales
1400 six kilomètres parcourus avec un
litre d'essence c'est la performance
réussie par cet engin conçu par les
élèves du lycée la joliverie de nantes
il s'agit du record du monde de la plus
faible consommation de carburant
un record établi à une vitesse moyenne
de 25 km heure une mise au point de la
direction d'antenne 2 et de fr3 après la
publication vendredi par le monde de
deux rapports de la cour des comptes
hervé bourges s'élèvent contre la remise
en cause du le site de la sincérité des
informations données depuis les 15 et 17
avril au conseil d'administration et au
personnel des deux chaînes on peut
s'interroger dit il sur les motivations
réelles des auteurs de ces fuites
la dernière partie de ce 19 20 sera
consacré à la religion et au cinéma
la religion tout d'abord avec le
pèlerinage des catholiques
traditionalistes de paris hb à un
catholique traditionaliste en effet en
pèlerinage mais en pèlerinage au pluriel
les fidèles du mont seignol les fidèles
de monseigneur lefebvre sont allés de
chartres à paris les autres ont fait le
chemin inverse mais les deux cortèges ne
se sont jamais croisées reportage sur
les traditionalistes et non les
intégristes fr3 orléans sur la route de
chartres des dizaines de milliers de
pèlerins beaucoup de jeunes venus de
toute l'europe pressé de leur ennemi
thème choisi cette année par le
pèlerinage de chrétienneté le christ
notre liberté bien aux marchands pour la
liberté de la famille en condamnant
l'avortement en condamnant cette masse
cette persécution qui pèsent sur les
familles chrétiennes
on les a surnommés les tradi de l'église
de france
ils se disent être d'église tout
simplement peut être pour mieux marquer
la scission avec l'autre pèlerinage
celui des lefebvristes
et pourtant aujourd'hui on parlait d'
appartenance à la même église
même si l'on ne marchait pas dans le
même sens
je crois que certains d'entre nous ont
20 par mois mais certains ont rencontré
effectivement des membres de notre
pèlerinage est bien ce qu on peut
maintenir c'est l'amitié entre nous et
certaines valeurs communes en espérant
et bien que tout le monde rentrera dans
le sein de l'église à la risée la grand
messe pontificale sera célébrée selon le
rite de saint pie 5 par le cardinal
augustin mayer président de la
commission romaine ecclesia dei et
l'évêque de chartres de son côté
rappellera l'autorité de rome dans
l'église enfin messe de conclusion du
pèlerinage de chartres paris les fidèles
de monseigneur lefebvre ont assisté à
une cérémonie en plein air au pied du
sacré coeur plusieurs milliers de
personnes étaient présentes et un torero
a dû être touché par la grâce à nîmes
il a épargné l'animal à la grande fureur
du public
un geste que le 19/20 apprécie
particulièrement reportage d'affaires
prend montpellier novillada émotion ce
matin après un accident du torero
saint-julien spectaculaire s'il en est
un qui n'aura pas de conséquences très
graves
un coup de corne sous l'aisselle
et un taureau de guardiola nommé
téléphone aux qualités exceptionnelles
avec nobiliaire de talents manuels
monteuil un ensemble qui fait des
étincelles en maul à l'ucl nous vivions
aussi grande qualité que manuel montoya
en demande la grâce simon casas
directeur des arènes l'appui et le
public si vous tenez vous bien parce
qu'on ne puis pas le taureau c'est très
bon pour la corrida en france ça montre
qu'on n'est pas systématiquement des
gens qui boulons la mort du taureau même
quand on le tue on me passe à mort quand
on le touche pas ce qu'a appris la vie à
la mort et que toute façon c'est une
chance irrémédiable et quand on peut
l'éviter
quand l'homme quelque part peut agir sur
ce destin fatal et c'est heureux moi je
suis très heureux voilà et c'est très
bien
allons maintenant à cannes avec thierry
stop fleurs pour connaître le palmarès
du festival c'est une autre corrida tout
aussi pacifique
la soirée avait déjà bien commencé pour
barton fink des frères coen qui avait
obtenu deux prix d'entrée la mise en
scène pour joel et ethan qui réalisent
ces films à 2 et puis le prix
d'interprétation masculine pour john
torture nos barton fink un film qui se
déroule dans le monde hollywoodien
moment d'émotion intense avec la
révélation féminine de ce festival
l'actrice française d'irène jacob qui
interprète la double vie de véronique
prix d'interprétation que vous donnez à
la double vie de véronique et comme un
prix qui est rarement tout seul merci à
la générosité des acteurs qui ont
participé à ce film un film signé du
polonais krzysztof kieslowski
c'est son premier film réalisé en
coopération avec un pays de l'ouest
européen
et puis à l'instant la palme d'or la
palme d'or a été attribué la palme d'or
du festival du court métrage à
l'unanimité barton fink de giovanni
seulement voilà les par cohen qui fait
déjà venu à cannes notamment avec
arizona junior et qui ont leur a parfois
reproché d'être un peu léger cette fois
ci c'est la consécration suprême donc
pour ces deux américains ce soir pour ce
festival de cannes
cela ne vous empêche pas d'aller voir
d'autres films qui n'ont pas été primés
ce soir comme le van gogh par exemple de
pialat avec jacques dutronc tout de
suite et pour terminer les résultats du
tiercé quarté + qui se courait
aujourd'hui pour le tiercé las le 7 le
17 qui apporte dans l'ordre 2922 francs
dans un ordre différent 584 140 le
quarté + à 7 17 9 qui rapporte 22 1898
francs 40 et dans un ordre différent tu
2443 francs 20 et si vous vous apprêtez
à prendre la route pour rentrer chez
vous écoutez bien les conseils de notre
bison futé de michel touré écoutez bien
aussi ses prévisions météo pour ce soir
demain et pour les autres jours ce 19 20
terminait bon soir à demain 19h devant
soi
jeudi
fr3 présente la météo avec jardiland
bienvenue madame mademoiselle monsieur
pour renouvelle du ciel de france demain
soleil assez généreux pensée arrosée au
jardin ou aux plantes de balcons car il
ne pleuvra pas de la semaine mais oui
voyons ensemble la situation générale
tout de suite avec un anticyclone qui
s'installe bien sûr la france hélas 1035
à 1030 à 1025 hectopascals et pourtant
nous avons encore la visite de nuages
pourquoi et bien parce que c'est quand
même une instabilité celle ci par
exemple y aura nous visiter cette
perturbation mercredi ou jeudi pour
l'heure pour demain celle-ci s'évacue
alors que se passera-t-il au lever du
jour six sept heures du matin sur
l'ouest c'est-à-dire normandie bretagne
jusqu'aux pyrénées occidentales des
brumes débrouillards peux te nas assez
dense quand même prudence si vous prenez
la route
et puis du soleil sur le sud est c'est à
dire du roussillon aux alpes jusqu'à
l'accord franc soleil dès le lever du
jour
ailleurs des frontières du nord au midi
toulousain beaucoup de nuages une
importante masse nuageuse voyons
l'évolution de ce taux en cours de
journée ensemble tout de suite sur
l'ouest du sud de la seine aux pyrénées
occidentales soleil du nord pas de
calais de la seine maritime à l'alsace
jusqu'à l'ariège alternance de passages
nuageux et de belles éclaircies
ailleurs des alpes du nord au roussillon
jusqu'à la corde soleil un peu moins
vaillant sur la côte méditerranéenne où
une petite bruine poussera doucement
quelques escouade de nuages bas cumulus
et stratocumulus températures matinales
entre 5 et 13 degrés en légère
régression dans le dans le dans l'ouest
et puis partout ailleurs et bien stable
ou en légère hausse voyez avec moi tout
de suite 5 à aurillac 7 à clermont
ferrand grenoble 8 à alençon 9h à
rebours strasbourg brest lyon bordeaux
toulouse 10 à lille nantes bastia 12 à
paris et 13 vos cordes et matinal pour
nice et perpignan et celle de l'après
midi via il suffit de demander pour les
avoir pour tout savoir
vous voyez 18 à cherbourg 21 le havre
dijon clermont-ferrand 22 metz brest 23
lille paris 24 heures 25 toulouse non
perpignan et 26 concorde jours à venir
pour bordeaux et montélimar au passe
vite les frontières on va voir ce qui se
passe chez quelques voisins tout de
suite on jette un oeil quoi moscou
vienne athènes copenhague de la
grisaille berlin/rome hal gill belles
éclaircies longue madrid-lisbonne du
soleil de ma 21 mai au fait les
costentin belle soit avec nous sur fr3
gert landes fait c'est fini
ce soir à 20h45 a surenchéri deux avec
doux dur et dingue un film de james
fargo avec et clint eastwood et sandra
loc
tueur par trop charmeur à l'est de lons
entraîne le clan des siciliens sur le
mortel chemin des règlements de comptes
sans fin certes wac gpo tension
le clan des siciliens mené par jean
gabin et autres est kepa lino ventura
est fixé sur pellicule par henri
verneuil lundi à 20h40
oui inventons il a des roues sans alcool
aux